وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه فرض عقوبات على
39 كيانا قالت انها تساعد ايران في التهرب
من العقوبات وتسهيل وصولها الى نظام
المالي العالمي وفدى بيان لوزاره الخزانه
ان هذه الكائنات توجد في ايران وباكسان
والصين والامارات وتركيا مشيرا الى نهايه
مليارات من الدولارات سنويا لصالح ايران
عبر مساعده شركات
ايرانيه على الوصول الى نظام المصرفي
الدولي
هذا ويختتم في فيينا اليوم اجتماع مجلس
محافظ الوكاله الدوليه لطاقه الذريه وكان
ممثل ايران لدى الوكاله محسن نذير اصل قد
دعا الدول الغربيه الى التخلي عما سماه
سيناريو رابع خاسر وتغيير موقفها اتجاه
ايران واضاف خلال كلمه امام الاجتماع
محافظ الوكاله في فيينا انا على اطراف
الاتفاق النوويه تحرك في عمليه تؤدي الى
حل المناسب للقضايا محل القلق المشترك
بدلا من معالجه قضايا سابقه وراى اصل انه
تم اثبات عدم فاعليه ما سماه النهج
الاستدادي فيما يتعلق بايران
من مقر وكاله الدوليه طاقه الذريه في
جنايه ضبئ لنا مراسل الجزيره محمد بقالي
محمد ما المتوقع كنتيجه لهذا الاجتماع
لمجلس محافظ الوكاله الذريه
يمكن ان نقول ان هذه الدوره قد تمكنت من
تجنب الاسوا والاسوا في مجلس محافظ
الوكاله الدوله الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه الذي كان يمكن ان يحدث هو اصدار
قرار يدين ايران
والجميع يبدو انه قد توافق على تجنب هذا
السيناريو الذي كان سيؤدي الى مزيد من
التصعيد سواء من الجانب الاوروبي او من
الجانب الايراني هذا هو التقييم
الدبلوماسي
لكل الاطراف المشاركه في هذه الدوره ان
التصعيد قد تم تجنبه ولكن بقي سؤال وماذا
بعد التصعيد تم تجنبه وفقا للدبلوماسيين
المشاركين في هذه الدوره بالنظر الى
الزياره التي قام بها المدير العام
للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه الى ايران
قبيله الاجتماع وبالتالي تمكن من انتزاع
تفاهما مع طهران بشان وعود للوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه بتعاون افضل في
المستقبل هذا الامر تمكن النزعي فتيل
التوتر ومن تخفيف الاحتقان وهو الامر الذي
دفع الى الاوروبيين على وجه الخصوص الذين
كانوا متحمسين الى اصدار قرار يدين ايران
دفعهم الى التراجع خاصه في ظل تردد امريكي
على هذا المستوى ولو كان هذا الامر قد حدث
لكان التصعيد سيد الموقف وهذا الامر هو
الذي عبر عنه
البارحه ممثل روسيا لدى المجلس هنا في
حديثه للجزيره قال انه ان هذه الدوره يمكن
تقييمها بانها ايجابيه لانها لم يصدر عنها
قرار يدين ايران لكن هذا هذه تجنب التصعيد
هذا وقته وبمثابه كسب للوقت وفقا لكل
الدبلوماسيين الذين تحدثنا عنهم لان
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه لم تتوصل
مع ايران الى اتفاقات نهائيه وانما توصلت
الى اتفاق اطار عام يقضي بالتعاون تفاصيل
هذه هذا التعاون لم يتم تحديدها وانما
سيتم التوافق بشان من خلال الاجتماعات
التقنيه التي سيجريها مفتش الوكاله مع
نظرائع مع الوكاله الايرانيه للطاقه
الذريه خلال الايام المقبله وخلال
الاسابيع المقبله وبالتالي فاعين كل
الاطراف هنا وخاصه الغربيين الذين قالوا
انهم سيراقبون ما اذا كانت ايران ستلتزم
بهذا التعهد ام ان الامر كان مجرد محاوله
لامتصاص الغضب الغربي وتجنب قرار للادانه
وبالتالي يمكن ان نقول باختصار عبد الصمد
ان الاسوء تم تجنبه ولكن الايام المقبله
والاسابيع المقبله ستكون سيكون الجميع
سيراقب الجميع ما الذي سيحدث اما ان يتم
فعلا تحقيق تقدم واما ان يعود الجميع الى
مربع الازمه في حال ما لم يتم التواصل بما
لم يتم التواصل بشان الاجراءات التقنيه
وهنا يمكن ان نلخص بان
عوده بان باختصار
هناك نقاط رئيسيه عبد الصمد تثير مخاوف
الغرب تتعلق بتخصيب الايرانيوم بنسبه 60
في المئه بالجزيئات التي وجدت بنسبه 84%
من اليورانيوم في مواقع ايرانيه ثم
المواقع التي تقول الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه انها غير معلنه والاهم من كل هذا
الذي يثير القلق اكثر في لدى الغربيين هو
ان كل هذا حدث في غياب رقابه الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه ايران ووعدت بانها
تتعاون مع الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
اشكرك محمد محمد البقالي
وكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه في غينيا
شكرا لك